Jake Paul looked more like a boxer than
Nate Diaz did on Saturday night and
that's because that's all he does Nate
does it but he also has to worry about a
lot of other things so you saw some of
his technique with his feet are leaving
the ground the way he would he would
kind of Rush in in in in his distance
and just kind of off balance in this
weird so it looks sloppy but in MMA that
works because when you get so close and
you can use the grappling you can use
over unders you can wear the guy out
Nate was doing a lot of that that's his
default mode that's what Nate Diaz does
well he wears you out applies pressure
uses volume and melts guys inboxdent
doesn't really work like that there's a
different dance you know there's
different frequency so I I think some of
the hate goes oh that was terrible
boxing yes you can't look at a kid with
seven fights and a guy with zero boxing
fights and go man that's bad boxing
compared to Spencer Crawford it's two
completely different products